Abby Betty I'm so happy to chat with you
both about the show the final season
it's phenomenal I loved all the episodes
so far it has been so intense for both
Kathy and Wright and I'm wondering what
was the biggest surprise about your
characters this year that you never
imagined coming I think for me
personally I didn't see Kathy getting
caught up in his world and you know in
season one they were so separate what he
did and and the life that he was leading
when you know outside of their
relationship
um
it was yeah it was just it was so cool
to just be in it for a minute yeah
um also Betty uh Wright is in a tough
position this year with the confirmation
hearing and our hands are tied with a
lot of what's happening with Jack can
you tease you know what her Direction's
gonna look like this year oh wow it's
it's a bit challenging without giving
any spoilers
um
but we do see that she leaves the ivory
castle of uh the CIA and goes out into
the into the world
um and so that's kind of
I think intriguing and and within that
uh as she's having this sit down with
the president Nigerian president she
they this is a really
interesting conversation where they
explore topics that I was surprised I
was like this is the Jack Ryan Show and
we're talking about being you know black
I think that's I think that's great and
I think the audience hopefully will
be sort of like oh
or like yeah yeah for sure Abby um Kathy
is back and I know a lot of fans are
really excited uh we're when we're
looking at the original books and then
the movies it's also Jack's last chance
to make things right with her so what
can you share about the relationship
this season and the test they'll be
going through so in this season we come
into it
and they've already decided to to be
together so to give their relationship a
second go I think at the end of season
one it's open-ended and and not they
weren't entirely committed to each other
so it's kind of cool like straight off
the bat we have two people that we want
to see together that are together
they're actively together and it's
really sweet yeah uh and Betty I love
how you um share a lot of scenes with uh
Wendell's Greer this season uh how has
that relationship grown to what it is
versus you know season three when you
guys basically all first met right it
didn't seem like we were all in each
other's corner at first well you know
Greer and Ryan yeah they're two peas in
a pod but I was the the foil and the
sort of adversary so to speak uh but
here at the top of this season after
what they were all went through last
season uh we see that they're almost
especially with writing where there's
one really touching scene there's a
couple of them and and we see that
they're almost family and to see his
family his actual family and how
complicated that is that reality is
I don't know there's just a really
beautiful juxtaposition of the The
Courier family the work family and the
family family
um
that I think is quite quite lovely and
yeah real I think one of the interesting
things about watching this season was
that there was the theme of family
permeating in every
um scene like every episode and it was
like found family it was making a family
like Jack trying to get back with Kathy
and then obviously we saw Greer and we
saw little elements also of um you know
right she had somebody but we don't know
much about it so you know with that sort
of family aspect obviously I feel like
this is also a show like personally I
watched this with my sister and my dad
and like we love it so much so this is
one of those things where I feel like
you know when you have a show this broad
is like what does it feel like for you
guys making these shows when there's a
huge audience watching it and relating
to it and you know especially those
actual nuggets that are something that
you can relate to not the action
sequences we don't all just drive off
cliffs like like jacked up right yes I
mean it's a pleasant surprise I think
you could just ease just as easy really
make it all action-packed all gun toting
and and it would still do well but these
these moments these slices of life
really being folded in and you know you
you create a bigger Fuller
character with all of them and that and
I think that's so rewarding for me as an
audience member that's what I want to
see I want to see the entirety of a
human being not just them flying off a
building yeah
yeah you got to come back this season
and so I'm wondering what was that like
was it like coming for like a school
reunion was it just like coming back
like was it because I feel like a lot of
elements have changed also the
production was higher I feel like there
was more you know going outside for
shooting and stuff so what was that like
yeah I mean strangely enough it felt
very similar
um when we Shot season one we were in
Montreal so we had a Canadian crew and
for season four we're in Budapest with
the Hungarian crew so that that was a
different experience for sure our behind
the scenes in terms of the show
everything felt very much the same it's
crazy to think that so much time has
passed from 2017 to when we shot last
year in 2022 I mean it's wild right but
um but yeah it was sort of an easy thing
to step back into in a way did each of
you have a favorite moment uh filming
this season maybe even for both of you
maybe the entire series like was there
something that when you filmed that you
were like oh this is a very special show
for me like this is going to be
something that goes with me wherever I
go I enjoyed just getting into the
action a little bit that was really fun
yeah it was it was cool I felt like a
big kid you know I got to do some of the
stuff that the guys were doing so it was
fun I did not get to do any fun things
but I I do what I consider fun uh
especially this season was um I got so
it was scary but I got to walk into a
room full of people as a senate hearing
room yeah I gave I gave this big
beautiful speech
and it's it's really I feel almost feel
like there's a little badge of honor
it's invisible but it's like a little
badge of honor or accomplishment as an
actor to do that to just sneak in a room
full of people
yeah so um you know before I let you
guys go Abby I know that we got to see
you know Kathy really take off this
season and we get to see more of also um
Wright coming into her own being that
you know what what happens at the end
I'm not going to spoil it but um I'm
wondering do you think there's a
possibility we could see your characters
come back or maybe even a spin-off
series with Michael penis character
since he is one from the Clancy original
Creations yeah I'm not sure I mean
there's so this there's so much content
you know in terms of in terms of the the
Jack Ryan Empire and also in terms of
the characters so I'm not sure where
anything will end up but
it's fun and it's exciting and people
people love the show so yeah I'm very
excited about it but thank you again and
on that note I will say congrats and
just express my gratitude for this show
it's great and I'm so excited for
everyone to see it so thank you again
thank you so much